we're talking about the kansas city
chiefs what you need to know today three
days left until our hiatus travis kelsey
appearing on sirius xm nfl radio
evaluating how things went down last
year for the super bowl 54 champs here
he is
well i mean i'll say
i took a note from the bulls uh
when they were they were
you know winning their championships and
and had their
had their run uh they don't mean a thing
if you ain't got the ring baby
all those accolades all that stuff it
might be cool when i'm
i'm sitting down on the couch watching
the young guys try and chase the record
but when right now
none of that really meant anything and
last year was a failure to me to be
honest it's just that's just what i have
in my heart this is the type of player i
am man if
we're not going out there winning super
bowls man the season isn't a success
hey and that's a fair assessment when
you consider the team that he's
currently part of he was there for a
while before patrick mahomes once
patrick mahomes arrives everything
changes you're a super bowl contender
every year and if you don't win it you
are going to be upset they were the
better team they were favored to win but
they were too banged up they didn't
react on the fly the fact that they
didn't have the top two tackles did a
poor job of protecting patrick mahomes
yeah and they came up against tom brady
a guy who had been there nine times
before there's value in that and uh so
the chiefs have that hunger that fire
rekindled
you know so many people are thinking the
bucks are going to repeat i mean who
knows maybe we'll see
back-to-back
conference champions and it'll be like
bill's cowboys that's the last time
isn't it we saw
the same teams get together in the super
bowl in consecutive years i feel like
you're right but i don't think i am no
no i think that's it i think bill's
cowboy is the last time we've had a
repeat super bowl matchup for sure isn't
that the only time that's ever happened
uh that's got to be the only time that's
ever happened i think again i feel like
i'm missing no i think you're right i
i'm i i'm pretty sure yeah there's
there's no i mean not back to back like
that you're right that's the only one it
definitely is and it's uh i mean they
were still as cowboys have gotten
together three times but but
consecutive same year same team and it
wouldn't surprise me if it happened the
chiefs are gonna have a harder road i
think than the buccaneers but the chiefs
are more determined because they tried
to get back to the top of the mountain
and they failed so this year
winning the super bowl is an improvement
over what happened last year for the
bucks it's just hey go climb that same
mountain you already climbed with you
know a bigger target on your back but it
doesn't surprise me i talked to travis
kelsey during the season
after one of their wins and
you know they viewed the loss to the
raiders as a disappointment as a glitch
is something to learn from
and kelsey's attitude was we don't plan
on losing another game anytime soon and
the only the only game they lost other
than the super bowl was a game that they
didn't care about we were 17 against the
chargers yeah yeah no i mean they
they have an incredible belief in
themselves and a showmanship and just a
competitive desire that that makes them
great i mean i think that's what's kind
of unique about them you know we've
heard them what is it chris jones we're
going to win six super bowls with they
have never shied away from
like putting pressure on themselves
or
telling us their expectations that's
kind of what's cool about the the kansas
city chiefs it's kind of hey we're here
we're awesome we expect to win every
game and for the most part they do yeah
they they fell into a buzz saw and you
you explained it right about the super
bowl bad you know beat up football team
bad game plan where they thought it was
going to work the same way it did the
first time around that didn't work so
i would expect to see a motivated kansas
city chiefs football team this year
they're going to be disappointed by the
super bowl but here's the big question
there's like there's twofold to me here
there's one like we've talked about
maybe a few weeks ago when we said
are they going to be
you know maybe exhausted from being the
marked man you know you could have the
super bowl hangover loss that aspect of
it you know these long seasons they've
had it's an afc championship game and
two super bowls in a row that that's the
thing where you look at negative but the
positive mic to me at least here to
where you go you know why i think they
can answer the bell and and get back to
the big game or at least close to it
there's they had some turnover on the
team you know there's going to be some
new guys there that are going to be
hungry to be like wait i want to win
here in kansas city that offensive line
what they did there geron reed so
there's going to be some new juice in
the locker room that hasn't quite you
know had the benefit of being on this
team and all the all the greatness about
it and i do think that could help them
at least a little bit motivate the
locker room and those guys their
excitement will rub off on the rest of
the team because they're like yeah man
this is good yeah you guys are excited
you should be we're awesome uh that
could be a positive for them when all
said and done no i i think you're
absolutely right i've said time and
again that one way to avoid complacency
is to bring in guys who have zero rings
and for them hey this is great i'm with
a team that is a contender this this is
a hell of an opportunity for me and i
want to get my championship and i want
to be part of something special and i
want to play with patrick mahomes and
and everything that goes along with it
you you knock off some of that rust that
can develop when it's the same roster
over and over again
um
you mentioned travis kelsey saying last
year they want to win six you're not
travis kelsey it was chris jones jones
right tyree kill has said something like
that right here's the reality
if they're gonna win six
chris jones is gonna be gone by the time
they get probably to number four right
tyree kill's gonna be gone the only guy
that's gonna get six rings is is patrick
mahomes just like tom brady tom brady
got the six in new england nobody else
got six in new england that's how it's
going to be it's not going to be
winning six out of seven or six out of
eight that that and as i say that i'm
i'm thinking watch it's gonna happen but
but that's just not we we saw last year
that's not how it works too many things
have to line up just right to win a
super bowl they're going to be in the
conversation yeah every year they have
patrick mahomes the question is how many
years can they thread the last needle
and make it happen and one thing about
super bowl 55 that doesn't get discussed
nearly as much as it should that brit
read incident from thursday night
awful accident right and ever and all
the distraction that that causes changes
it's the the son of the head coach of
the team 72 hours before kickoff that
had to have been a huge factor in
just what seemed to be a chief's team
that wasn't ready to answer the bell
yeah i i agree uh you know the beat up
factor maybe a little complacency and
hey like hey we're the man we've already
beat this team we're gonna do it again
but the brent reed thing yeah is real
there's no doubt about that i mean
imagine like you you said it it's the
head coach's son he's a coach on the
football team you know this happened it
was a horrible event
like what do you think the chiefs
players were talking about in the locker
room friday and saturday when they got
in there like what that's they weren't
talking about the super bowl they
weren't talking about the game hey did
you hear what happened to coach's son
hey man what happened did you hear any
of the details where was he what
happened i mean that's that's that's
distraction big time you're right i mean
you take that into account hey some of
those questionable calls by the referees
we saw all that i mean clearly tampa was
the better team that day but that is a
distraction and uh they haven't had to
deal with too much like that they
usually answer the bell all the time and
this is one of those games for the first
time i think really in the mahomes era
where we were like we were on the edge
of our seat we kept thinking it was
going to happen they'll get it close
they'll step on the gas pedal here and
it just didn't happen that day they
couldn't overcome all of it and i think
it's all the circumstances we're talking
about
and the other twist to it as well they
didn't get a chance to really process
what happened on thursday night because
they were still in kansas city they
traveled
late to tampa because of the pandemic so
it just was a weird upside down ending
to a weird upside down season and you
throw all the ingredients together and
it just proves how hard it is i mean how
they almost didn't get their first one
they're down 10 points with seven
minutes left this is not
the kind of dominance
that we've seen in the past because the
teams are too tightly packed together
especially at the top right there isn't
one great team there's seven great teams
and any of those teams can win the super
bowl then it comes down to the bounce of
a ball a bad call or a good call
depending upon your perspective a fluke
gust of win whatever it can be a special
player making a
think about the effort that is put into
everything that happens
from the start of the season
until the end of the season all you know
the old bill parcells this is why you
lift all them weights yeah right all
that work all that effort it comes down
to some fluke that's completely out of
your control yeah no it comes down to
you know you're getting the biggest game
of the year and you lose your starting
left tackle and you lose another office
alignment and your quarterback's playing
on you know one foot and dealing with
that issue with the turf toe and all he
can't play to his best ability you know
it was rare to see them you know in that
scenario and i mean you're right the day
of that's what's made new england
special like we don't have the 80s and
90s dominant team there wasn't salary
cap there wasn't free agency then it was
like major league baseball you kind of
knew the five or six teams that were
going to be the real deal holy field and
going to be in the mix of the super bowl
that's the way it was it's not that way
anymore that's what makes it you know of
course amazing what new england did but
even amazing what we're seeing here
right now even though it's one super
bowl i mean yeah it's close you know
they've won some games where you could
sit here and go i don't know if they
were really better than san francisco
they might have got a lucky call and
they just had the best player on the
field that's the biggest thing and he is
the ultimate eraser or you know gap
filler whatever you want to say he is
amazing at if the game's close you feel
like kansas city is going to win because
15's at quarterback and he's just going
to make the play to do it and that's
what makes them special and kind of fun
too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports